léonard arrête de ronfler
c'est épouvantable ce run de mahler
offre tellement fort que je n'arrive
même pas à lire cela fait deux heures
que je suis sur le même article le même
paragraphe et je n'avance pas
c'est infernal et c'est comme ça tous
les jours et si par hasard on leur
réveil il est tellement de mauvaise
humeur qui grognent jusqu'au soir
ça ne peut quand même pas duré et non
non non je il paraît que quand on siffle
un sahara qui ronfle le mans
voyons voir
pourtant rien à faire non non il faut
que je trouve autre chose à part
peut-être tous ces poussées
et c'est désespérant j'avais senti
peut-être alors attention avec une
chanson et un peu d'imagination
je vous emmène au
nom
encore pire
je ne vois pas de solution
ah si peut-être joué là le morceau de
clairon que m'a appris mon oncle
archibald
voyons ça
[Musique]
non toujours en rien alors là c'est
vraiment désespérant parce qu'il paraît
qu'avec ce morceau là au réveil des
régiments entiers
non tant pis bon je crois que je vais
abandonner mon article est allé faire un
tour dans le jardin ça vaudra mieux
pourrait mettre le réveil sur sa malle
il sera bien obligé de l'entendre non
bon tant pis pour mon article ça me
changera les idées
casimir
tiens c'est bizarre m'a dit qu'il ne
voulait pas sortir toute la matinée
il ya quelqu'un
a peut-être que léonard et dont staline
a
déjà un nom c'est moi qui ai fait tomber
le réveil mais qu'est-ce que vous
fabriquez ici c'est à plusieurs mais
personne n'a répondu arrêtées seraient
vaines il faudra arrêter le réveil c'est
ce que je vous dis fervent arrêté serait
vain oui
[Musique]
mon dieu quel silence on entend les
oiseaux chanter quelle douceur
tranquillité
gens très bien qui sent pas non non non
les honneurs pas avant d'avoir autour de
la nouvelle extraordinaire que je
voulais apprendre à quasiment figure toi
que je me batte mon propre record de
brasse papillon et la nage au monde la
plus fatigante la plus difficile et qui
demande un style particulièrement soigné
en fait une nage qui est fait pour moi
quoi qu'en pensez vous mais j'en suis
très heureux pour vous ceux du snob
pouvez vous faire une petite
démonstration
à mettray vélo très longue et je peux
prendre cette table oui bien sûr je vous
regarde de tous mes yeux alors voilà
voilà voilà il suffit deux
ont donné le corps là tu vois comme un
serpent tout en bas et avive les bras
avec les bras tu vas comme un papillon
très doucement voilà
fort bien cher fulbert anselme fort bien
vous êtes vraiment très brillant très
remarquable vous évoluez sur ce tabouret
comme un poisson dans l'eau à l'honneur
c'est vraiment le renard le plus gentil
de l'est aux enfants ouais vous ne
prenez pas de risques monsieur du sein
en ligne en a pas d'autre mais pourquoi
ne nous feriez vous pas une
démonstration dans l'eau cette fois ce
serait sûrement un grand plaisir pour
nous c'est le spectacle le plus rigolo
que j'ai vu depuis longtemps
en france
alors oui c'est la maison casimir mais
il n'est pas là comment mais si vous le
savez pourquoi lui téléphoner vous
ces trois casimir oui oui oui oui
monsieur du snob et la wii
casimir demande ce que vous faites cet
après-midi ou écoute j'ai une idée
extraordinaire on devrait faire un
concours de brasse papillon jusqu'au
rocher bleus qu'en penses tu oui
monsieur du sne on propose une course de
brasse papillon jusqu'au rocher bleus
ouais non oui
d'accord c'est ça très bien d'accord dit
alain
et bien
c'est d'accord monsieur du stand dans
une heure nous avons rendez vous sur la
plage en attendant je vais faire une
visite à mes amis au revoir et bonne
préparation à tout à l'heure en moins
oui et j'ai également une compétition à
organiser j'ai un travail fou oui les
vacances sont déjà bien loin et spa
facteurs
je crois que vous vouliez m'entretenir
d'un sujet particulier
oui voilà casimir j'ai promis à ma
demoiselle futé de l'aider pour son
herbier pour sûr ça ne m'ennuie pas mais
tu m'accompagnes aurait que ça ne me
dérangerait pas un oui je dois continuer
mon expédition à travers l'île pour
ramasser eu des plantes les plus rares
c'est parce qu'on a tout simplement faim
mais si elle genre de plantes
extraordinaire vous voulez vous prouver
dans cette équipe mais on y trouve
toutes les plantes et les plus rares
casimir tu n'es pas sans ignorer que
nous bénéficions d'un climat et d'une
végétation particulièrement favorable
enfin nous avons dans cette île des
spécimens tout à fait remarquable vous
avez trouvé ça tout seul mais oui
pour sur madmoizelle fuite m a convaincu
alors casimir jeu tu m'aider
eh bien j'hésite vraiment j'hésite un
que vous voulez voir vous me proposait
d'aller ramasser des feuilles dans les
bois et monsieur le snom a proposé une
promenade en mer alors je ne sait plus
que faire moi
on écoute et nous allons tirer au sort
avait d'accord d'accord attention une
souris verte qui courait dans l'herbe un
jeu la trappe parra que jean la montre à
ces messieurs ces messieurs me dise
tromper landreau il trouvait là dans
l'eau ça sera un escargot tout chaud 1 2
à 1 deux patries un deux trois ans voilà
on vraiment c'est tombé sur vos facteurs
l'ipad choses vous allez aller ramasser
vos feuilles tout seul tant pis moi je
vais je vais en meyrin à brasles et
amusez vous bien et toi sois prudent
remy que le honte quel scandale d'autre
part permet des choses pareilles tiens
je redis vos nommé juge la compétition
un homme aussi honnête que vous aurez
mis fins et escroquerie que s'est il
passé monsieur du snowboard ou son
casimir et léonard ici nous pouvons la
verdure un cas alors le compte de
monsieur du chemin car nous avons gagné
la course nous l'avons attendu trois
cars 2 sur le rocher bhl ou quel
scandale cinq minutes au maximum trois
quatre cinq minutes trois quarts d'heure
montre en main c'est bon alors disent
pas plus de 10 minutes aura de toute
façon nous avons gagné grâce à mes
supers l hyper légère super
aérodynamique la fac la pop pop virage à
gauche dirige droit cours à marrakech
par nils à monter sur son dos et j'ai
nager la brasse dans l'air avec mes bras
et mes jambes je ne vois là rien
d'anormal casimir a droit ou titre de
vainqueur
moral bien qu attendez vous donnez moi
ma récompense
mais casimir je ne sais pas si ça va te
plaire un postier mais si ça vous plaira
bon tu acceptes mais bien sûr je les
accepte et bien alors comme prix je te
cèdent le titre de premier assistant de
mademoiselle futile voilà non non non
non non
tu lui rapportera toutes ces plans
nouveau
monsieur du stop je vous en prie je vous
invite à boire un bon chocolat chaud
d'année venez au revoir mon petit
cadenas héros
[Musique]